[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
احييكم
وهذه العربي
اوكرانيا بين كفتين دفعه الدبابات
البريطانيه تنعش مالك يافا لكن طول الحرب
وزخم الحشد يدعمني موسكو
اعدموا ايران لاكبر قد يكون رصاصه الرحمه
للاتفاق النووي وتل ابيب تلوح بنك اهدافنا
زاد واسلحتنا الجاهزه
من الوثائق السريه
عن ايامه الاخيره كان نائب للرئيس
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
وسط نفق الازمه المظلم في باكينج فرصه
للمصالحه بين هاري والعائله لكنها مشروطه
باعتراف الكل بالخطا
[موسيقى]
من الحرب في اوكرانيا ومن التاكيدات
الجديده على الخلافات في صفوف القوات
الروسيه على اختلاف تصنيفها
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
في اوكرانيا مشددا على استقلالهم عن الجيش
الروسي
لدى مجموعه هو الذي سمح لها بالسيطره على
مدينه سوليدار
بمثابه انتقاد مبطن جديد للقياده العسكريه
العليا والتي يتهممها كثيرون من انصار
بوتن بالافتقار الى التنسيق وعدم فهمي
واقعي الميدان
اولا لقد كانت قوه فاجنر تقاتل منذ سنوات
عديده قد يكون الجيش الاكثر خبره الموجوده
اليوم في العالم ثانيا يقومون بجميع
المهام بانفسهم لديهم طائرات حربيه وهناك
جيش بطولي من الطيارين الذين لا يخشون
الهلاك لديهم انظمه اطلاقه صواريخ متعدده
من جميع الانواع وهناك دفاع جوي اسقط عددا
كبيرا من طائرات العدو ولديهم انظمه
مدفعيه من جميع الانواع والكوادر
والدبابات وعرابات المشاه القتاليه
[موسيقى]
لكن الانتقادات للدائره المحيطه بالرئيس
لا تتوقف على العسكريين بوتن نفسه وبخا
وزير التجاره والصناعه بسبب بسبب التاخر
يا طاهر في توقيع عقود طلبات الطائره
المدنيه والعسكريه
انا اخبرك لننهي هذا الاجتماع الان لماذا
نزعج بعضنا البعض اخبرني المديرون انه لا
توجد عقود في الشركات لماذا تلعب دورا
الاحمر متى ستكون هناك عقود هذا ما اسالك
عنه اخبرني مدير المؤسسات انه لا توجد
عقود وتقول ان كل شيء جاهز
شهر 10 من الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا نظيره
لهدوء لهدوء الاجواء جوا وارضا وبالاصح لا
علامه فارقه تنتشي بان نهايه الصراع بين
موسكو وكاف تلوح في الافقي القريب بل ان
معارك ضاريه تحتدم تاره وتهدا تاره اخرى
لكنها لا تؤثر في سخونه الحرب فها هي
بريطانيا تختاروا لنفسها ان تكون اول دوله
ترسل دبابات غربيه غربيه الصنع الى
اوكرانيا بل وتعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه ريشي سوناك بارسال اربعه 10
دبابه قتاليه من طراز تشالنجر 2 الى كاف
خلال الاسابيع المقبله ومن المتوقع ان
يتبعها بل ان يتبعها قرابه الثلاثين من
المدافع ذاتيه الدفع من طراز اي اس 19
يديرها خمسه من المدفعيين سوناك اسر ايضا
على ضرو تدريب القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
على استخدام الدبابات والمدافع تلك ذهبت
صحيفه ميرور البريطانيه ابعد من ذلك
بالتاكيد على انك ستحصل من لندن على ما
يصل الى اربع مروحيات من نوع باتشي لكن
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه نفت هذا الموضوع
في بيان رسميا
[موسيقى]
ربما يكون النفي والبريطاني لموضوع تزويد
كيف الاباتشي مراعات للخطوط الحمراء لان
مروحيات
اكثر تقدما والقادر على تدمير اهداف
متعدده في ثواني اما بالنسبه لتشالنجر 2
فتصفها الشركه المصنعه بانها دبابه القتال
الرئيسه الاكثر موثوقيه للعالم والتي لم
يستطع العدو يوما ما تدميرها ويمكنها
اصابته ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في الدقيقه
الواحده دعم لم يدخره هناك بل انه كان قد
اكده مع الرئيس الاوكراني
في اتصال هاتفي اعرب فيه عن طموحي بلاده
في تكثيف الدعم لاوكرانيا عسكريه
بالشكل الذي يؤمن لها النصر والسلام في
النهايه
قدم رئيس الوزراء بيان لمحادثه التي
اجراها مع الرئيس زيننسكي وسيصدر وزير
الدفاع اعلانا كاملا الى مجلس العموم
الاسبوع المقبل دعمنا للشعب الاوكراني في
دفاعه عن النفس ضد العدوان الروسي لا
يتزعزع واعتقد ان البيان او الاعلان الذي
ادلى به رئيس الوزراء هو انعكاس لذلك
كان هذا هو الاعتراف البريطاني لكن الامر
بطبيعه الحال لا يتوقف على لندن راويه
صحيح طاهر من بريطانيا نتحول الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي اعتراف علاني بان اما هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا مادن في شهوره وربما
سنوات وعلى لسان عده شخصيات اوروبيه اجمع
ضمني يعني في كل تصريحاتها على قول واحد
ان الحرب ستكون طويله العمل من بين هؤلاء
الامين العام للامم المتحده
الذي اعرب عن اماله بانتهاء الحرب في عام
2023 بالرغم من كونه لا يرى اي احتمال
لاجراء محادثات سلاما في المستقبل القريب
ويعتزم الاتحاد الاوروبي فرضا حزمه جديده
من العقوبات الاقتصاديه على موسكو خلال
المرحله المقبله بعد ما اقر التكتل المكون
من سبع و20 دوله
العقوبات منذ بدء الهجوم في فبراير من عام
2022 حتى امين حلف الناتو ينس ستولتنبر
قالها بفمم الان لا تستهين بروسيا رغم
انتكاسها يجب ان نستعد لحرب طويله الامل
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا لاننا راينا ان روسيا كبدت خسائر
كبيره بسبب الجنود الاوكرانيين الشجعان
الذين يتمتعون بكفاءه المهنيه ويمارسون
ذلك بتفان لكن يجب ان لا نقلل من شان
روسيا انهم يحشدون المزيد من القوات
ويعملون جاهدين للحصول على المزيد من
المعدات والذخيره وقد اظهروا استعدادا
للمعاناه فعليا لمواصله الحرب كما لا يوجد
مؤشر على تغيير الرئيس بوتين للهدف العام
لحربه ضد اوكرانيا لذلك نحن بحاجه الى
الاستعداد لحرب طويله
وبهذه الاعترافات يجد الغرب نفسه في شبه
ماء ازرق ويتحول من المسانده الى المصارحه
ليسال نفسه ماذا عن جاهزيتنا لو طال امل
هذه الحرب صحيفه وصف جون الامريكيه اشارت
الى ان الحرب كل ما طال امدها ستصب في
مصلحه روسيا رغم انها تكبدت بعض الخسائر
في الاونه الاخيره بل ان روسيا تراهن على
فقدان الغرب الحماس تحديدا امل ها في ان
تشب الخلافات بين الدول حول مؤيد
لاوكرانيا ومعارض لها حتى الان لم تحقق
ايا من الرهانات والدليل ان اوروبا خلصت
اعتمادها على الطاقه الروسيه دون كوارث
السياسيه لكن الصحيفه تاكدت انه برغم ذلك
فان الحرب الطويله ستكون لصالح موسكو
واوروبا ليست مستعده لهذا النوع من الحروب
ولا حتى الولايات المتحده ففي الماضي حولت
روسيا اقتصادها الى اقتصادها حرب في
المقابل لم تقم واشنطن ولا حلفائها باجراء
اي تعديلات في الانتاج العسكري
لنختصر قليلا ما قالته الصحيفه ببساطه ان
روسيا دمرت صناعه الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وجعلتها تعتمد على الاسلحه الغربيه لكن
مشتريات الدفاع الغربيه وعمليه التصنيع
على عكس روسيا تلتزمان الى حد كبير
بالاجراءات والجداول الزمنيه في اوقات
السلم
ورغم مصادقتي الكونغرس الامريكي الشهر
الماضي على حزمه مساعدات بقيمه
44.9 مليار دولار لدعم اوكرانيا لكن سيطره
الجمهوريين على مجلس النواب تعني ان
التمرير المزيد من هذه المساعدات العسكريه
والمدنيه لك يافا سيكون اكثر تعقيده
وانجاز القول فان روسيا امنت على
احتياجاتها العسكريه فمن ناحيه المعدات
الحربيه هي تواصل تصنيع ما يلزم من
الذخائر وتوسع انتاجها لمواكبتي وتيره
القتال خاصه بعد ان وعد درس طول امد الحرب
مبكر واذا ما قرنا القوه العامله فانها
ايضا بحسب والسجون لتصب في صالح روسيا
التي حلت هذه المشكله وحشدت 300,000 جندي
احتياطي كما يبلغ عدد سكان روسيا 3.5
اضعاف عدد سكان اوكرانيا اي ان روسيا حتى
لو خسرت جنديين مقابل كل جندي اوكراني فان
المعادله البشريه تثبت قوه النسبيه لروسيا
واكدت الصحيفه ان التعبئه الاخيره سمحت
للرئيس بوتن بتحقيق الاستقرار في خط
المواجهه وشان هجوم مضاد حول مدينه بخموت
في منطقه شرق اوكرانيا وفي هذا المضمار
والايفو دالدار سفير الولايات المتحده
السابق لدى النتو الذي يراس مجلس شيكاغو
للشؤون العالميه ان اي فكره عن عمليه
السلام قد ولات لان بوت يبذل قصار جهده
للتاكيد على ان الحرب باتت معركه وجوديه
بالنسبه لحم مقابل ذلك فان ادوارد سترينجر
الرئيس السابق للعمليات في هيئه اركان
الدفاع البريطانيه يارا ان الغرب يدعم
اوكرانيا بالقطار اي ما يكفيها فقط كي لا
تخسر حاليا
وبفعلته هذا فانه يطيل امد الحرب بيديها
هذا بالاضافه لازمه اخرى تتعلق باروقه
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه في تركيا
ابراهيم كالون ان بلاده ليست في وضع يسمح
لها بالموافقه على طلب انضمام السويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي تصريحات كالين هي احدث
موقف تركيا غاضبا من تظاهره في ستوكهولم
تقول انقره ان ان صار حزب العمال
الكردستاني علقوا فيها دميه لاردوغان في
تصرف وصفه الاتراك بالمهيم قال ايضا ان
احاله ملف انضمام ستوكهولم وهلسنكي الى
البرلمان ربما سيكون في يونيو اي حتى يصوت
البرلمان السويدي على تشريعه طلبه تركيا
الغضب التركي تصاعد بعد رفض السويد تسليمه
بولند كنيتش احد المطلوبين لدى تركيا
وكذلك موافقه الحكومه على وقف تسليم اربعه
مطلوبين الى انقره في ضوء هذه التطورات
سيعقد اجتماعه ثلاثي بين تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا قريبا ربما تستضيفه بروكسيل وقال
وزير الخارجيه التركي ان بلاده قبلت حضور
الاجتماع
ومن اسطنبول نتحول الى كافو وينضم الينا
من هناك حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه اهلا بك
حذيفه يعني هل من تفاصيل حول موعد وصول
ال- اا اسلحه الغربيه الدعم الجديد
لكيفا نتحدث طبعا عن تشالنجر وغيرها من
المعدات الثقيله وما يحكى حاليا باروقه
السياسه الاخرانيه عن تخوف من جفاف هذا
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا ماذا في التفاصيل
مساء الخير راويه لك والي الزميل طاهر في
الحقيقه اذا كان هنالك مخاوف في اروقه
الحكم او القياده الاوكرانيه فقد تبددت في
الساعه الاخيره بعد ان صرح ينسولك قبل
حوالي ساعه وقال في تصريحه ان لابد من
يعني زياده الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا وقال
اننا سنواصل دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
الثقيله ورحب طبعا بقرارات المنتخب
بعض الدول لنقل الاسلحه ثقيله الى
اوكرانيا وقال ان هذه الحرب الان هي في
مرحله صعبه جدا وقال ان هي في مرحله حاسمه
كذلك لذلك علينا ان نواصل دعم اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه الثقيله التي ستساعدها على النصر
وهو مطمئن تماما اولا همم راويه تعلمين ان
هناك همم طبعا همم وهو
يجمع وزراء دفاع الدول الشريكه لاوكرانيا
وهنا نتحدث عن وزراء دفاع جميع الدول حل
الفنيه وكذلك بعض الشركاء الاضافيين
واوكرانيا هذا المجلس هو مجلس استشاري
امني لديه رجال ولديه عدد كبير من
العاملين على عمليه ايصال المساعدات
وعمليه تحديد نوعيه المساعدات المطلوبه
الان وهم يدرسون الحرب يوما بيوم ويعلمون
ما الذي تحتاجه اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله
لذلك اوكرانيا يعني هي مطمئنه تماما بخصوص
مساله همم الدعم العسكري ونوعيه الدعم
العسكري وطريقه ايصال الدعم العسكري اما
بخصوص الدبابات بريطانيا هي ليست الاولى
التي همم وافقت على نقل الدبابات الى
اوكرانيه سبقتها فرنسا وكان قد صرح بذلك
الرئيس همم اوكراني بعد محادثه اجراها مع
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون والذي قال
ان الرئيس ماكرون وافق على نقل الدبابات
اي ام اكس 10 الى اوكرانيا وكذلك نقل
المدرعات الناقله للجنود الى اوكرانيا
وهذا الامر سيتم ايضا في خلال اصابع كذلك
بعد الحديث مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اا
متصرح ان الامر سيتم في خلال الاسابيع
ولكن حدد ذلك وزير الخارج او وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني الكثير زنكوف الذي قال ان في
خلال شهرين سوف تصل هذه الدبابات في
الغالب تشالنجر كذلك برلين الان تدرس
عمليه نقل ليبرت همم 2 وهي الدبابه
الالمانيه وهذا القرار سيد يتخذ قبل على
20 من شهر من هذا الشهر قبل ان يجتمع همم
قبل ان يجتمع مجلس تايم الذي سوف يحدد
طبيعه الدعامات ونوعيه الدعومات قبل ذلك
سوف يتم اتخذ القرار من برلين طبعا
انه ستكون هناك كيف تفهم همم
التاخر في ارسال نوعيات محدده من الاسلحه
او رفض ارسال وضعيات محدده اخرى من هذه
الاسلحه التي تفيد كيف كثيرا في معاركها
نعم طبعا اكيد دائما هنالك تصريح من
المسؤولين الاورانيين حول اسلحه معينه
طبعا نتحدث عن انظمه الدفاع الجوي وايضا
نتحدث عن قاذفات الصواريخ وهنالك طبعا بعض
الاسلحه بعيده المدى والاسلحه الهجوميه
كذلك التي تستطيع ان تصل الى العمق الى
داخل الاراضي همم الروسيه هذه هي نوعيه
الاسلحه التي حتى الان هنالك تردد كبير من
قبلته في ارسال مثل هذه الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا طبعا اوكرانيا تقول انها اذا
استطعت ان تحصل على اسلحه هجوميه تستطيع
ان تسترد اراضيها في خلال اسابيع ولكن
طبعا هذا سوف يصعد كثيرا من الوضع بين همم
روسيا بين حلف الناتو وكذلك سوف يصعد من
طبيعه الهجمات الروسيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والدربات الصاروخيه خصوصا لذلك
هنالك طبعا تردد من قبل همم الشركاء في
ارسال مثل هذه الاسلحه لكن هم يستعد يجرون
الوصول مثل هذه الاسلحه وي والان طبعا عين
اوكرانيا على الطائرات مقاتله هجوميه هذا
ما تطالب به في الفتره الاخيره خاصه بعد
الضربات يعني كل ما تكون هنالك ضربه على
منشات لي البنيه التحتيه او هنالك ضربات
لمباني سكنيه ويكون هنالك ضحايا دائما
يخرج المسؤولين الاوكرانيين وخاصه في مكتب
الرئيس عن اوكراني ومستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني دائما ما يخرجون بلاجات غاضبه
ويقولون انهم في حجه ماسه الى اسلحه
تستطيع ان تحمي او تغلق الاجواء او تقوم
بحمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيات طبعا كما قلت
ان هذا المجلس يجتمع بشكل دوري وهذا
المجلس هو يرصد عمليه الوضع الميداني
وبناء عليه تتم الموافق على نوعيه الاسلحه
التي يمكن
لا يريد ان يكون هناك تصعيد كبير همم على
الارض لذلك يتم ارسال الاسلحه بقدر الحوجه
على ارض المعركه المفهوم شكرا جزيلا لك من
كيف حذيفه العربيه
شكرا
في تداعيات الحرب الاوكرانيه اشار تقرير
لوكاله بلومبيرغ الى ان اسواق الوقود
ستكون على موعد مع صدمه جديده اعتبارا من
الخامس من فبراير مع تطبيق سقفي سعر لهذا
الوقود واشارت بلومبرج الى ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيتعين عليه استبدال نحو 600 الف
برميل من واردات الوقود الروسي يوميا
او لخفض الانتاج في مصافها كما توقع
مراقبنا ان ترسل الصين المزيد من الوقود
الى اسواقها القريبه مما يدفع شحنتها بشكل
غير مباشر نحو اوروبا
للنفط الخام الروسي ستقوم باعاده تكريره
قبل بيعه مره اخرى الى اوروبا
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
البرهان يطالبوا السياسيين السودانيين
بعدم التحدث في شؤون الجيش
[موسيقى]
انا حسيت الاسنان مشكله شائعه مره معجون
سنسوداين المطور ترميمه حمايه الجديد
بيدخل لعمق السن وهذا بيساعد فانه يقلل من
حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم ما
يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
هوايه محفوفه بالموت وشرف قد يحول الصياده
الى فريسه هم طالعين لسه يعني
طير اخذ موجه الريح وصعد ناحيه الرمال
اللي هي المغريه جدا كيف تحولت تراث تربيه
الصقور
يدفنون
من عائله واحده كبيره
السقاره في مصر مهما خاصه السبت
ال9:30 على الشاشه العربيه
توليد الطاقه قطاع النقل والمواصلات
الوقود واكثر من 300,000 منتج اخر ليلعب
دورا مهما في الاقتصاد العالمي
لكن في ظل التطورات التي يشهدها العالم
والبحث المستمر عن مصادر متجدده للطاقه
كيف سيكون المشهد
تعرف على كل التطورات واخر المستجدات
المؤثره في هذا انقطاع الحيوي من صناع
القرار وخبراء العالم مستقبل الطاقه مع
ناصر الطيبي الخميس السادسه والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في ايران تجاهل النظام
دعوات الداخليه والخارجيه واعدم المواطن
البريطانيه الايراني علي اكبر بتهمه
التجسس
ضحيه لم يكن الا وسيله للنيل من هدف اكبر
بعد اعدام علي رضا اكبر المثير للجدل
وردود الفعل الغربي المهدده تظهر تطورات
الاحداث في ايران ان عمليه الاعدام ما هي
الا مقدمه لصدع متوقع في هيكل النظام
الايراني
وليس ادل على ذلك ما سرب من حديث اكبري مع
القاضي المكلف بمحاكمته
فواحده من التهم التي اعدم اكبر بسببها هي
حصوله على معلومات سريه عن الدوله من امين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي هشام خاني
مقابل زجاجه عطر وقميص
وهنا كان سؤال اكبري البدايه للقاضي اذا
كان شمخاني سرب هذه المعلومات اليه فلماذا
لا يحاكم معي
لكن رد القاضي كان مفاجئا اذ قال للشاكي
ليس لدي القوه لاستدعاء شمخانه لكنني
سادمرك انت
طبعا كل هذا بالاضافه لما تعرض له اكبر من
تعذيب لفتره طويله ان انتزعت خلالها
اعترافاته قصرا
السؤال الذي يدور الان بين دوائر
المتابعين هل كان اكبر هو الهدف ام شم خان
نفسه
ايران انترناشونال قالت وفقا للوثائق حصلت
عليها من داخل الحرس الثوري ان الاطاحه
بشم خان هي الهدف الاكبر مما حدث لاكبر
وحتى الشبكات التابعه للحرس الثوري على
تلغرام تناولت معلومات عن اقاله الرجل لكن
المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
نفى ذلك تماما بل ان الحديث امتد الى
خليفته القادمه وتم التركيز على وزير
الداخليه احمد وحيد باعتباره صاحب اكبر
الفرق
ويرى معارضون ان النظام قد يكون في مرحله
محاسبه من يعتقد انهم خذوه خلال موجه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
الى التدخل لاخماد الاحتجاجات
ووعد بالسعيد لتقديم مزيد من الحريه
وتحقيق بعض مطالب المحتجين هذا النهج لم
يرق لصقور النظام الذين راوا على الدوام
ان القبضه الحديديه هي الحل لعلاج كل
المشكله
لم ينتهي الشهر الاول من عام 2023 بعد لكن
يبدو انه سيكون عام الاختبارات على الاقل
بالنسبه لاتفاق النووي المترنحه هل سيبقى
ام سيدفن فكل المحادثات التي اجريت في
اغسطس الماضي لاحياء تعثرت بعد توتر
العلاقات بين ايران والاطراف الغربيه
المعنيه بما فيها الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل متزايد كل ذلك
بسبب الحمل الصارمه الدمويه التي يشونها
النظام الايراني ضد المتظاهرين عدا عن
بيعها لطائرات مسيرات عسكريه لروسيا في
هذا السياق حتى بريطانيا اعادت النظر في
دعمها للاتفاق النووي الايرانيه عام 2015
بعد اعدام المواطن البريطاني الايراني علي
رضا اكبر وفق ما ذكرت صحيفه
اعلنت بريطانيا التي تعد طرفا رئيسا في
المحادثات النوويه التي تستهدف احياء
الاتفاق استدعاء السفيرها من ايران مؤقتا
للتشاور ردا على اعدام اكبر وقال مصدر
حكومي انه خلال فتره المفاوضات تغير
المشهد وتغيرت المعطيات بشكل كامل بسبب
سلوك النظام الايراني فيما اشار 10
داونلود الى ان جميع الخيارات قيد
المراجعه اي ان بريطانيا التي كانت
متفائله بحذر بشان اعاده احياء ان يتفاق
النووي يبدو انها تراجع موقفها مليا طبعا
دون ان ننسى ان الاتفاق بالنسبه للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن شبه ميت بالفعل منذ
ديسمبر الماضي حتى المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروس اكد ان
المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران وصلت الى طريق
مسدوده وتوقفت اما وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كلافلي فاضح ان رد بلاده
على اي بخصوص اعدام اكبري لن يقتصر على ما
تم اتخاذه من اجراءات مشيرا الى ان المزيد
قيد الدراسه
الى النظام الايراني مفادها اننا نراقب عن
كثب ما يفعلونه وسنرد بقوه على اي اجراءات
يتخذونها وعليهم ان يدركوا ان الاحتجاجات
التي يشهدونها في جميع انحاء ايران هي
مظاهرات شعبيه مدفوعه بسبب الاجراءات التي
يتخذونها ضد الشعوب بهم
وبالتاكيد بريطانيا اليست وحدها في حاله
الغضب العارم مما تقوم به ايران ونظامها
بما يخص التظاهرات هناك من يلوح برد فعل
اكبر واضخم يا طاهر اذن بريطانيا طبقه صين
او ادنى من المضيق قدما في خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه فاعدام ما اكبر غير
الموازين لكن امر البرنامج النووي بالنسبه
لاسرائيل شبه محسوم ربما لانها بكل
الاحوال تنظر اليه على انه اكبر تهديد
محتمل اقليميا وعلميا وعليه فان رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي المنتهيه ولايته
الجنرالذيذ كخافي قال ان بلاده مستعده
لمهاجمه المنشات النوويه الايرانيه حتى
بلا مساعده الولايات المتحده مضيفا ان
العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
يمكن ان تمنح النظام الايراني الفرصه
لتحقيق اول قنبله نوويه في غضون اسابيع
قليله مع تخصيب كافن لليورانيوم واردفه
مؤكدا ان اسرائيل تملك مقرا كاملا يركز
على انشاء خطط عملياتيه لمهمه مهاجمه
المنشات وانها بدات بالفعل بتدريبات
روتينيه في الاشهر السته الماضيه
وقبل يوم واحد من انتهاء ولايته ادلب كل
هذه التصريحات بل انه زاد عليها ان
اسرائيل باتت رهن اشاره القياده لتدمير
المواقع الايرانيه قائلا ان بنك الاهداف
في ايران قد اتسع خبر يتضافروا مع ما
اعلنه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو قبل
نحو اسبوع عن ان اولويه حكومته تصدي
للنووي الايرانيه قائلا ان تل ابيب ستعمل
بصوره قويه وعلانيه على المستوى الدولي ضد
العوده الى الاتفاق النووي وليس فقط خلف
ابواب مغلقه
[موسيقى]
لكن يبدو ان تل ابيب حاولت امتصاص حديث
كخافي اذ قال مصدر عسكري اسرائيلي قال ان
خطه بلاده لشنه هجوم مستقل على منشات
ايران النوويه ليست جاهزه بعد ولكن قد
يتغير الوضع في حال استقبل الجيش اوامر من
المستوى السياسي
العسكري ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيواصل
التجهيز لضربه عسكريه لايران عبر شراء
مقاتلات وذخائر خاصه ثم ذكر باهميه
الغارات الاسرائيليه على سوريا وذكر
بدورها في تعطيل موضوع ايران العسكري بحسب
وصفه اوكرانيا
ترصد اداء ايران بتفعيل المسيارات في
اوكرانيا ولديها حلول لمواجهه هذه القدرات
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الكشف عن
وثائقي سريه جديده في منزل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بيدن يضع مستقبله السياسي تحت
المجهر
والمقابل يعطي الفرصه للجمهوريين لتوجيه
التهم للرئيس بل والمطالبه بفتح ملف
الاسابيع الاخيره في فترته كنائب للرئيس
ناديه البلبيسي والتفاصيل
يوم ان هادئ في البيت الابيض لكنه ينظر
بعاصفه سياسيه فمشاكل الرئيس القانونيه
تتراكم بعد الكشف عن وثائق سريه جديده في
بيته ليصل المجموعه الوثائق الى 20 وثيقه
بعض المحامين المحافظين يرون بان بيض في
خطر اكبر من الرئيس ترامب الذي احتفظ
بحوالي 300 وثيقه في منتجعه في مارالرجو
ورفض التعاون مع المحققين والمحامين
والتهمه بعرقله
والسبب ان ترامب انه نزع السريه عن تلك
الوثائق امر يخوله الدستور حسب بعض
المحامين المحافظين لكن هناك انقسام في
وجهه النظر القانونيه التي تقول بان هذه
الصلاحيه هي من صلاحيات الكونجرس وليس
الرئيس ومهما كابرا او ثوره حجم الخطر
المحيط ببايدر فهناك مساءله ق وشيكا في
مجلس النواب وهذا قد يؤثر على فرص الرئيس
في الترشح لولاده ثانيه
وتبقى معنا من امام البيت الابيض مراسله
العربيه ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك معنا
ناديه لا اعرف الى اي مدى يعني كي يوم احد
يمكن ان يكون هناك معلومات جديده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن يعني
نسالك هذا السؤال لتحدث فيه لنا معلومتنا
في فتره ما بعد اعدادك لهذا التقرير
في الواقع سبايدر مان موجود اليوم في
اتلانتا لاحياء ذكرى ماتن لوثر كينج غدا
ايضا هو عطله فيدراليه في الولايات
المتحده لكن الرئيس ينتظر هذه العاصفه
السياسيه عندما يعود هنا اليوم الاحد يوم
اجازه كما ذكرت لكن كل البرامج الحواريه
الامريكيه كانت تتحدث عما يحدث الان
للرئيس من متاعب قانونيه وسياسيه ليس فقط
لانه هذه الوثائق سريه والرئيس في ادرك
تماما اهميه عدم الاحتفاظ بها لكن لان
البيت الابيض لم يتمتع بالشفافيه يعني في
كل يوم هناك ايجار صحفي كل الاسئله لنا
تتركز حول هذا الموضوع طبعا اللي جريمه
همم كريم جينر لكن حتى الان البيت الابيض
ربما يحاول ان يتهرب من الاجابه ويقول بان
الموضوع هو قيد التحقيق في وزاره العدل
وبالتالي اي اسئله صحفيه يجب ان توجه الى
المستشار او المحامي الخاص بالبيت الابيض
لكن على كل كل يوم نكتشف ربما وثائق جديده
حتى لو قال البيت الابيض بانه لا يمكن عقد
هذه المقارنه مع ترامب للاسباب التي
ذكرتها قبل قليل وانه كان خطا والى اخره
لكن فكره انه عندما كان نائب للرئيس طبعا
لا يدرك بان هذه الوثائق لا يجب الاحتفاظ
بها بمجرد بان يغادر البيت الابيض عليه ان
يسلمها الى السجل الوطني هي ال- المشكله
الاساسيه يعني من ارتكب هذا الخطا عاد على
انه المعلومات التي في داخل هذه الوثائق
بالفعل قد تكون سريه او حتى غيه في السريه
لا نعرف حتى الان منذ ان بدات هذه الفضيحه
السياسيه اذا اردت للرئيس لا نعرف همم
معلومات كثيره سواء ان بعض هذه الوثائق
تتحدث عن ايران وعن بريطانيا وعن اوكرانيا
البعض اليوم بالتحديد يحاول ان يربط بين
موضوع اوكرانيا وموضوع هانتربايدن همم انه
نعيد ان تذاكر المشاهدين ربما بان كل هذه
الازمه السياسيه التي بدات في رانيا في
عهد الرئيس ترامب وتعرض لمساءله قانونيه
ومسائله من الكونجرس هو علاقه الرئيس
ترامب عندما طلب من مسؤولين في اوكرانيا
بفتح تحقيق ضد عنتر بايدن مقابل اعطاء
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا والان يقولون
بان ربما جزء من هذه الوثائق السريه التي
صنفت تحت اسم اوكرانيا قد تكون لها علاقه
بهانتر بايتنز باين لكن هذا الاتهام ياتي
فقط من المحافظين او من بعض الجهات
الجمهوريه ناديه يعني المحامين ابلغوا منذ
شهرين عن هذه الوفاق لكن الكشف عن الابلاغ
تم مؤخرا وهنا يبرز السؤال حول من تستر
حول يعني تسريب او الاعلان عن هذه الوثائق
لما بعد انتهاء الانتخابات النصفيه
ماذا حول هذه النقطه
واكثر من ذلك تماما تماما راويه واكثر من
ذلك هل الرئيس اخبر بانه هذه الوثائق تم
العثور العثور عليها في الثاني من نوفمبر
والبيت الابيض هو الذي قرر الا يتحدث علنا
او انه فقط المحامين او المقربين من
الرئيس قرروا حمايته بين قوسين وبالتالي
بمجرد العثور على هذه الوثائق تم ابلاغ
وزاره العدل لكن لم يتحدث عنها احد لم
تسرب المعلومات للاعلام والبيت الابيض لم
يتحدث عنه طبعا في دفاعي البيت الابيض
يقول بانه طبعا طالما ان هناك تحقيق من
قبل وزاره العدل لا داعي للمتحدثه باسمه
او اي مسؤول كبير في البيت الابيض ان يعلم
الامريكيين او الاعلام بوجود هذه الوثائق
لكن اكيد هناك الكثير من الاسئله
والرئيس بيض نفسه قال بانه لا يعلم ما هي
هذه الوثائق ولا يعلم انها موجوده وقد
يكون خطا غير مقص طبعا بنقل هذه الوثائق
كل رئيس ونائب رئيس لديه الالاف من
الوثائق التي تصنف سريه تقدم له في خلال
خدمته لكن البعض ينقل كما تعرفين يعني في
كل عطله نهايه اسبوع الرئيس ينتقل الى مقر
اقامته حسب همم طبعا الرئيس همم في حاله
ترامب كناذهب الى نيويورك
في ولايه لوير لكن تنقل هذه الوثائق معه
هل هو بالفعل خطا ام انه اهمال بغض النظر
سيكون هناك
تشريعيه في الكونجرس ومحاسبه من الاعلام
للرئيس وللمتحدث باسم البيت الابيض شكرا
جزيلا لك مراسله العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
من امام البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان دعم القوات المسلحه لكل
خطوه تقوده الى الانتقال الديمقراطيه
البرهان وفي كلمه القاها في مهرجان
الرمايه في اقليم النيل الازرق رحب
بالاتفاق الايطالي معربا عن اعتقاده بانه
سيوحد شمس السودان
ما عنده علاقه بالتنظيمات السياسيه ما
فيها اخوان ولا فيها يا ساريين ولا فيها
يمنيين ووات مسلحه سودانيه حق السودان هي
صمام امان هذا السودان عشان كده بنقول نحن
والله ماشي في التوافق نحن متوقع انه ما
تم توقيعه من الاتفاق ايطالي يخرج هذه
البلاد مين وحدته
واحد صفنا عشان نبني هذا البلد اهلنا
عانوا سنين طويله وبلادنا معنا سنين طويله
ما عندنا اي طريقه غير اننا نلبي نداء
الشعب السوداني
البرهان رفضا انتقاد المؤسسه العسكريه
مطالبا السياسيين بعدم التحدث في شؤون
الجيش والانشغال بالاهتمام باعمالهم
وبامورهم
[موسيقى]
كلام ده نحن بنقوله واحنا نموذج قدامك ده
دي مسؤوليتنا انه نحافظ على الجيش ده
بوحده متماسك قوي يحمي هذا البلد ويحمي
الدوله السودانيه وبنقول لاخواننا
السياسيين تتكلموا الجيش احسن تشوفوه
شغلتكم اهم شيء تكلموا
صفوفكم خلونا نحنا قادرين باننا ناخذنا
جيشنا في الطريق الصحيح
في العربيه 360 ايضا في بنجلاديش قطار بشر
حرفيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
تحت عنوان البديل وفقا لمصدر مقرب من
الامير هاري والعائله الملكيه فان صلح
ممكنه
وان كانت تتطلب تجاوز عقبات عده
من باب المصالحه قد يعود الامير هاري الى
اروقه قصر باكينجا لكنها قد تكون عاجله
قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث مايو
المقبل وفقا لصحيفه ساندي تايمز
البريطانيه
مصادر مقربه من الملك تشارلز والامير هاري
ترى ان اجتماعا قد يعقد بينهما في حضور
وريف العرش الامير ويليام خلال الاشهر
المقبله
رغبه حقيقيه لجلوس الشقيقين مع الملك
تشارلز في غرفه واحده ومصالحه ممكنه لكن
تقف في طريقها عقبات
حسب تقرير صنداي تايمز تتطلب المصالحه
الاعتراف باخطاء الماضي من قبل الجميع وهو
ما يحتاج الى مرونه قد يفتقدها هاري
الراغب في الحصول على اعتذار من العائله
الملكيه لزوجته الى جانب المساءله قبل
المصالحه
العقبه الثانيه تتمثل في نيران كتاب
البديل التي جعلت الامير ويليام يحترق
داخليا حسب وصف المصدر المقرب من الجانبين
فهل يستطيع وريث العرش الحفاظ على هدوء
بعد تركومات الخلاف مع شقيقه هاري
غياب الثقه المتبادله يظل حاجزا ليس فقط
من اجل اتمام المصالحه ولكن من اجل الجلوس
اولا فبحسب المصادر ينبغي وجود افراد من
الاسره يثق فيهم هاري حتى لا يعتقد انه
يتعرض ما
عقبه نحو المصالحه يسعى القصر الى تذليلها
وملك يرغب في تهيئه اجواء طبيعيه خلال
مراسم التتويج في مايو المقبل وان لم تهدا
الاجواء فقد تتحول الى مصدر الهاء وتشتيت
وفقا لمقربين من العائله الملكيه
علي السمان العربيه
اهلا بك معنا استاذ عادل مره جديده حول
هذا الموضوع
حجم مصداقيه مثل هكذا تقارير ان كان عن
ستاندي تايمز او عن غيرها من يتناول هذا
من الصحف التي تتناول هذا الموضوع حاليا
اه هو طبعا انا ما بحبش شاكك فيه تقارير
زملاء صحفيين لكن المعروف
صديق
لكل من الملك وولي العهد والامير هاري
هو يمكن ترجمتي الكتاب الفرق
الشروط اللي باضعها هو طبعا بيتكلم عن
السكرتير السابق
الملك
تشارلز بيتكلم عن اسقف كاترين
بريطانيا
وتزال في دائره الدعايه اللي بيعملها
الامير
المعلومات ووصلت العائله بالاخير يعني الى
لم شمل اعضاءها والمصالحه همم من سيكون
كبش الفداء من سيدفع الثمن هل الصحافه هل
الموظفين الذين تم التهامهم بالعنصريه من
لا يعني
كبش فداء لماذا يعني
جلاله الملك في النهايه هو اب
قى هو تدرب طول عمره
على يد استاذه لا مثيل لها في
الدبلوماسيه الملوك
الله يرحمها
وبالتالي فهو يعرف تماما اا
اهميه عدم اللعب بتصريحات اهميه اتقاء كل
شيء في السر وفي النهايه اب يريد
هو الامير هاري هو اللي ابتعد عن الاسراء
كان هناك يعني تحمل للمسؤوليه او الى حد
ما عندما قيل بانه همم يعني سيعاد النظر
همم يعني تم تسريبه عن انه هناك بعد
الدكيماتري او ال- ال- الوثائق الذي همم
يعني شاهدناه على نت فليكس بانه هناك
اتهامات بالعنصريه سيعاد النظر فيها
والتحقق من حقيقتها او لا وبالتالي هناك
همم ما نرتكب خطا يجب ان يتحمل المسؤوليه
حتى الان لا يوجد تصريح رسمي اعتراف بخطا
الصور مساله لا علاقه لها بالامير هاري
وهي كانت واحده مقربه في حفله في
قصر وسالت وحده انت منين وهي اصلا موجوده
هنا لانها جايه بملابس
لكن ما فيش في الفعل
الكلام
اي اصعب الامور راح يكون على القصر
او على الامير هاريكل همم يعني اي سيكون
اصعب الامور لتقار به او للتعهد به او
للاعلان عنه ربما
هو يمكن الامير هاري يعني بيفكرني
برئيس كوريا الشماليه بمعنى انه اكثر حاجه
يعني بتزعله انه نكون متجاهل ان هو ما حدش
يعني يفكر فيها او ما يكونش موجود الصحافه
والتلفزيون او الناس تتكلم عنه او يشتكي
من حاجه لكن بالنسبه للقصر هو التزام
بالصمت طبعا في النهايه همم القصر لا يريد
ان يكون هناك تاكيد للاكواه لكن الامير ان
يحترس لان لسه ساعات الرايق وتشير الى
انخفاض شعبيته بشكل سلام مثيل
شعبيته في الجيش وهي كانت ملانه الاخير
فعلا
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عادل درويش المراسله
المعتمد في مجلس العموم البريطاني تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
في العراق لا تزال وقائمه والتصريح لرئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد
ان القضاء على تنظيم داعش بمساعده هذه
القوات يحتاج الى مزيد من الوقت
بمباركه من قوى الشيعيه في العراق كانت
ولا تزال تنادي بخروج القوات الاجنبيه
بالكامل للنقاش
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من بنجلاديش
حيث يبدو الامر اشبه بمعركه حربيه محاربون
في سباق مع الزمن لتسلق الحواجز واخرون
يساعدونهم مع اقتراب ساعه الصفره
الاخيره من كثره التزاحم هذه المشاهد
عاديه
انه بعد كل حادثه قطار تثار الانتقادات عن
اسباب غير مبرره لسقوط عدد كبير من الضحك
اما فيديو اليوم من محمود الاوكرانيه وحيث
لم يعد هناك مكان في المشافي هذا لو كان
الوصول اليها ممكن اصلا تحت القصف لذا
باتت يا طاهر زياره الطبيب في ملجا تحت
الارض امرا اعتياديا بالنسبه لاهالي
المدينه
لكنه يشغل باله باله اكثر بما اذا كانت
احدى القذائف التي تسقط قادره على اختراق
المكان
معها كل شيء